[Music]
okay just got done seeing M night
Shyamalan 'he's new movie glass which is
third part of a series that had
unbreakable and the second one was
called split and it was it's basically a
superhero movie as told by M night
Shannon yeah it's like almost like a
naturalistic yeah yeah I really I think
he did a good job in kind of like
creating a universe based upon Marvel
Comics in DC what would it be like if
superheroes were real would you know
what would it be like if it was really
realistic and I think he succeeded I
think it turns out this this one is kind
of like an origin story
yeah the first trilogy is an origin
story for something more than you don't
want to give too much away because like
I said I mean in the trailers I mean
you're obviously seeing the thing where
James McAvoy is reprising his role from
the split as the split personality yeah
guy who's one of his personalities is a
serial killer called the Beast and
there's also samuel l.jackson and bruce
willis reprising their roles from
breakable yeah and they all kind of mess
up in a mental institution together and
things ensue yeah look we had fantastic
acting I thought it was a solid story I
had a really good time I mean I like
this in a certain way I kind of like
this more than Aquaman even though there
are very different movies yeah this is
uh yeah it's nothing like Aquaman but as
far as the superhero movie goes I like
this although I would have to say I
would definitely recommend seeing
unbreakable and split before this
because if you don't you'll probably be
able to figure out if you know like what
the kind of
RUP story of those two movies was yet it
will be much easier and you will enjoy
it more I didn't get to see split I'm
gonna go back and see it but I did see
unbreakable and I liked it yes so it
leat you at least have to see
unbreakable yeah yeah man I'm getting
split too but I don't think that's quite
as you know not a prerequisite or even
if because I didn't say split either but
I knew like what the you know what the
story was about so I knew what his
character was about yeah and he was
[ __ ] great in this yeah like I said I
haven't seen split and I heard he was
great in that too but just the way he
can like change personalities like a
dime like that not make it seem cheesy
it actually seemed very realistic and
kind of freaky freaky yeah yeah yeah
he's almost he's possessed yeah and he's
like a really good physical actor too
yes it's funny he's not a he's a
sawed-off little [ __ ] but he's like in
good shape but his because he's just so
fierce you know that is acting it you
buy it you know you buy that this guy's
super strong yeah because I don't really
think they do I mean obviously they did
some things like they showed in the
trailer where he was like running across
the yard like a cheetah then you know
where he's climbing walls and stuff but
when he's in the beast mode I don't
think they do much to him I mean other
than him just like blue veins like
public they don't you know what I mean
they don't CGI him out like it's got
like black eyes you know what I mean but
that's about it yeah it's mostly all
just him and his movements and when they
brought in a cool element that I really
liked is that there's an element of
belief and faith if you don't believe ya
if you don't actually believe you can do
this [ __ ] then you won't be able to do
it yeah but because these guys are just
amped up for you know psychological
reasons they can do it because they
believe they can yeah and I liked that
too I
they kind of played with the idea where
maybe they don't really miss Farish
maybe they just believe that they did
and if we take that belief away then
they won't be able to do them yeah
there's something to yes there's that
kind of like ambiguity about it too like
maybe these are crazy if you did they
really don't have superpowers so I like
that they kind of like played with yes
well hey I'm during my time in the Army
infantry I know that if you're
psychologically beaten down you will not
be able to do it yeah believing that you
can get this done you'll get it done
yeah yeah like I said you know I would
advise seeing the first to at least see
unbreakable before you see this one
otherwise you might not really know
what's going on yeah at least see
unbreakable but yeah I really really
like this a lot like I said the acting
was was great like everybody was great
in it just I don't really sell it play
out of a 10 out of a 10 I'd give it an
11 in the extra point you know give it a
lot of when he likes something yeah all
right guys you guys everyone
you
okay we just got done seen
vice which was a kind of like a
historical political satire slash
reenactment I guess a story of Dick
Cheney yeah and then kind of do you know
like the 9/11 the war in Iraq and and
everything I but also covered like him
working and working his way up like in
the Nixon White House yeah and then his
heart transplant there like it was quite
quite funny at times it was pretty
clever the way they did it had the guy
in the beginning who well I want to
spoil it
yeah please don't spoil that because I
didn't see that was cocaine yeah see the
whole thing it's like the beginning of
it I was like does this really mean a
narrator but they're like as it went on
you realize and then you realize who it
is that's like it was actually kind of a
clever
yeah the acting is fantastic Christian
Bale just [ __ ] knocks it out of the
park that's dick Jing really I mean is
that I don't know that looks just like
Dick Cheney it sounds just like it and
the dude that played Donald Rumsfeld did
a really good job in the office
Condoleezza Rice she that look like
Condoleezza Rice just like also Sam
George well yeah and George Bush and and
you me was also very good yeah and I
love Sam Ron and I think the overall you
know the the characters were treated
pretty fairly uh Roger stone who worked
with a lot of these guys who you know
he's a political commentators around
today
he's Republican he knew all these guys
he says yeah that's that's that that's
exactly what it really seems like
exaggerated and like I said you know
Bobby
we're old enough to flip through a
period but also I have read extensively
about this period and about all the [ __ ]
that was going on in the White House at
this time period and there's nothing in
there that was that was not that wasn't
that's you know everybody knows on [ __ ]
now wasn't it wasn't exaggerating the
only the Moot you're gonna say that the
movie does come from a left perspective
which of course they're gonna poke fun
at Republicans that's what they do but I
would kind of say that the acosta kind
of sounds me today that people are
shocked that this is the way leaders are
and that corporations have a lot of
power and it shocks me that people are
shocked that governments do things for
money it's always been that way and it's
always gonna be that way they're all
like this just like I said it is a very
it was a very significant political yeah
you know to a period and you know there
was they couldn't you have these people
in offices that have power and when all
that [ __ ] went down they had an
opportunity to make lots of [ __ ]
money and that's what they did it's hard
to say no to money and they even shut
one thing that will give the movie
credit for is it showed Hillary Clinton
doubt they're just stumping to go to war
with Iraq she was in on it too they all
are you know this is a business and
don't for one second think that these
people are fair government is the
ultimate form of organized crime that's
its really what it does and I'm
surprised that people are shocked at the
kind of people that flourish and survive
inside bureaucracies because there are
bureaucracies that naturally selects
people like this and it always will but
that said I mean as much as I am NOT
fan of Dick Cheney this actually I don't
want to say it humanized him but you
know because I don't like when you they
say what you humanize well he's a human
being
yeah not one that I personally care for
but you know he's still a human being
and they did show him as a multi-faceted
person just like all people are you know
it didn't like dampen down how like kind
of what a sociopath he is but he also
had a loving family you know he had a
line in the sand with his daughter he
was a lesbian
you know he kind of sold her out at the
end but you know what I mean it was all
about money everything's about money and
power but for a long time he wouldn't
let anything you know he sat out
everything about gay marriage and stuff
like that because his daughter was gay
but Paul still is farm I know but you
know so like I said in a way like as a
movie I actually cuz you know this was
pretty much the last thing we have to
see we've seen like everything I didn't
want to see this and it's like I did
want to see it because I like all the
actors but I was like oh god it's gonna
be politics and some you say depressing
but actually it was kind of depressing
but actually it was it's a really good
movie it's a well acted movie good
quality it's not you know it's not like
in a narrative timeline it kind of goes
back and forth there's like funny little
interstitial type stuff like there's one
part where they start like four six
reciting Shakespeare and like there's
one part like the credits for homeland
[ __ ] like that like they just have like
all these kind of key oh it's not cute
but you know these just funny little
side lines in there that kind of keep it
entertaining so it actually is an
entertaining movie even though it's kind
of like depressing subject matters if
that's not too weird a thing to say but
I actually enjoyed it a lot more than I
thought I would and I did give them I
give the writers credit at the very end
Dick Cheney looks at you and says you
know you care about what people think
about you you want to either be your
normal person you know your little
people you know you don't understand
that you know at this level it's
basically killer be killed at this level
you know or wish
yeah yeah and they have they've
apologized right so you got this is he
he basically he says you just have to
accept the world for how it how it is
and you have to accept things for the
way they're given to you and this is the
world we have and you don't like it and
neither do I was [ __ ] you and you know
that's from an accordion you have to you
know I'm not gonna say give the guy
credit but he started out like yeah he
was a nobody pretty much working on
power lines in Germany and he was just I
mean he just had that personality type
where one he's super ruthless and two
you know he knew the right people you
know he would always like listen and
know like the right people to approach
and the right you know to kind of get in
good he was very Makaveli yeah and I
also like that they they treated George
Bush pretty fairly was not shown as a
bad guy he's just shown as a very simple
guy who's trying to top his dad and
trying to be president basically but it
looked like Martin Hannett Dick Cheney
was really more like the president well
yeah that was the arrangement kind of or
at least that's how it was portrayed net
stone said yeah that's about it about
the way it was
yeah from everything I've heard of that
time very of them yeah yeah okay but
okay let me but my final analysis it was
a high quality movie I really liked it
excellent with this but I want to see
this again know was I having a really
good time and jump enjoying it now that
really it's kind of a downer yeah I
actually liked it's a downer but it's
funny like I said anakena kind of keeps
moving and like has enough entertain
stuff in it that you're not gonna be
like oh god please kill me I lived
through this [ __ ] so to me it's just
mundane and these people are kind of
kind of tired you know then you go back
and you see that old stuff and you
remember the thinking of the time yeah
because you know the thinking of the
thinking of the time times have changed
a lot I actually but as a movie and
entertainment now [ __ ] no I kind of like
replicas better well yeah yeah
okay we just got done seeing one called
serenity in Matthew McConaughey and who
was it who else was that one with you
know her name yeah Anne Hathaway it
movie stars you know back from when they
had movie stars I'm not sure they have
movie stars anymore but these guys came
from the era where you know I recognize
it do it as a movie star but what this
is a difficult movie to talk about
because we went into it with not knowing
anything really about it I wouldn't even
know what genre it was and it's kind of
a good thing too it's kind of like
though the less you know about this
movie the more this movie trips you the
[ __ ] out yeah so honestly okay I can
save this much because this much is
written on the little description
because seriously all we saw the poster
crop up we know nothing I said and I
read the little paragraph synopsis
basically the little paragraph synopsis
says this is basically a story about a
guy who lives in an island that runs a
fishing boat yeah and his ex-wife or
ex-girlfriend has married this horrible
abusive jackwagon and once basically
wants but here's the kicker that's not
what the movies about no not really
alright happens you're like what the
[ __ ] is happening
and it all starts falling into place and
then it gets it gets it gets weird it's
a good movie the acting is good the
setting the tone of the movie is just
right it has a very Caribbean feel to it
yeah I was going like is this in Florida
where is this they mentioned in Florida
and then just one thing and it big you
can't spoil it
it's very strange it reminded me of I
wanted to say I was kind of reminded of
maybe like Donnie Darko yeah something
like that
where it was kind of like you thought it
was one thing but it's actually
something else so yeah so I'd recommend
it would you I would but like I said
just don't read anything don't do
nothing about it just go and see it
you're interesting if you go see it yeah
you know yeah if you wouldn't want to
know the premise of this movie you
probably go oh yeah it sounds good but
[ __ ] that yeah but when you kind of see
it happen you like I yeah Wow okay yeah
cuz like the more it went on I'm just
sitting there going yeah right you know
what I mean and this just gets all these
little then it turns out it's a totally
different even as if in a totally
different genres and in so yeah I
recommend but yeah like I said it's
certainly weird and it's not like we're
expecting yes you go check it out
[Music]